as many of us in this room know as
there's Will Smith backstage it's not
just the phone call it's the invitation
of breakfast it's the lunch that lasts
exactly 47 minutes it's the follow-up
phone call is the visit to the office is
the tour of a facility it's a follow-up
phone call
it's a letter to remind you that you got
a phone call and headed toward the
facility and finally there's a thank you
for the contribution you made Jeffrey
Katzenberg is a public servant he began
that way you know he first started
working as a young man with much more
hair but no less energy for John Lindsay
the mayor of New York City
and that was back when New York City was
a raucous jungle of a place which means
for a few years
Jeffrey Katzenberg ran New York City he
did it by cajoling by running around the
city by parking any damn place he wanted
to and by making phone calls and having
breakfasts and inviting people the tour
facilities they're making followed by
phone calls at New York City was a
better because of it then he came out to
Los Angeles which as we know is a
raucous jungle of a place but luckily
without any of those snooty egos that
exist in New York City politics and he
continued this life of public service as
you've seen his infallible spirit his
tireless working is not just part of his
day job as will said it's part of his
Creed it's part of his DNA
he can't stop working for the betterment
of our city of our state of our industry
certainly and of our country
as you can see he takes care of us by
participating in the raising of funds
for institutions that take care of us
sometimes is our physical needs as we
they were the younger or as we grow old
sometimes it is our cultural needs in
regards to our schools our museums and
sometimes Jeffrey Katzenberg cannot help
but help take care of our spiritual
needs as he did and I believe it was
probably September 14th 2001 a few days
after the worst day that any of us can
remember in our lifetime Jeffrey
Katzenberg made calls only made calls
because it wasn't time to have the
breakfast meetings or take the tours of
the facilities but he called and said
we're gonna try to do something new
something different we have to break the
rules on this one and so less than a
week after September 11th 2001 great
storytellers were lucky enough to appear
on a telethon that was shown on every
single channel in the United States of
America and which actors told stories
about what real people went through on
September 11th have been fabulous
artists put their talents to work and
sang songs that brought us together and
healed the spiritual need healed the
spiritual wounds that we were all
feeling Bruce Springsteen sang my city
in ruins Tom Petty sang we won't back
down and Neil Young sat at a piano and
sang John Lennon's Imagine imagine all
the people living life in peace
that evening happened because of Jeffrey
Katzenberg other people certainly helped
don't I don't want to discount all the
efforts that went into that work but
Jeffrey Katzenberg was the peak of that
proactive Piron
that set a standard for the way
Americans help out America at times of
need every time something horrible
happens in this world be that a tsunami
or a hurricane there is now the
telephone that is on TV on most of the
channels in the country where everybody
who just sat back and witnessed is asked
to help to help the physical to help the
cultural and help the spiritual needs of
our nation Jeffrey Katzenberg doesn't
have to do any of these things but
Jeffrey Katzenberg cannot help but do
all these things it is in his DNA
Jeffrey Katzenberg is a brilliant man a
hard-working man a visionary and as well
as powerful a man who has ever been in
this raucous jungle of a city and
Industry of ours but more than anything
else
Jeffrey Katzenberg is a public servant
and as a my honor to present him tonight
the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award
ladies and gentlemen Jeffrey Katzenberg